true j0 нової болти 22 рок і мартін
шульц представляв слухати як
соціал-демократію про європарламент про
стане 5 руки як його президент сам і
почали європарламенту шульц звик сибая
копіри канон і я європеєць
шульц народи вся по блезуа хрону
нападали kardon sb ллють а нідерландам та
відразу ж з дитинства вигляд шумів поривах і
прикро та європи 63 одну річкову
політику розбавляти маму вам і дату
вже вин особи 100 знаючи богачук головних
стиснувши щось відлетить канава торговий зал
святу поважається за пристрасного борця за
ліберальну ідею це соціальну прикро
але і Європи і заборонив їм
противником націоналістичного популізму
у що набираю про бортик з він встановлений
завантажу найбільшим цивілізаційним досяжним
знанням віку коли небудь bull і на нашому
континенті у сима силам і я бюро там і
серце її на новиною та майбутньому
байдуже знайти посади у 2014 у шульц взявши
долею прогонах за на і ви що по саду
в дуже на к і в руку місії їх
зручний поступ і вся жанну колоду юнкеру
вибір що боротьба за віртуала його в тому
ж руки сама за глум його не шур порада
був ася 1 година на урок 6 ратифікація audi
про асоціації
україну це з європарламентом
верховній раді
шульц позики і читку позицію щодо
конфлікту на сході України
ж і вина за росію альтернативу та
дипломатії мій вигляд по так само однак
харчування 3 баста ви ти так їм шин цеху
чому ми вин з Росії моя відповідь
не а в такому разі набагато більше днів.
Михайлович та мінськ 34 та п'ятницькою 1000
шульц не боїться у гострих шляхах у
продемонструвала його ризик відкриті до
росії за камазу лід у наді риф на сході
україни так сирі та по 2 6 низькому brillan
axapta
ще робот росія абсолютно приємно за
всім агресивним ідеї марусі коштувати
концепція яншо вас встиг ства іншала
велика почет нижче нашої європейської
розумі немає 17 взаємо кухар і брудно
манить насті та відкритості suspense тва
там вгадаю послання європейців містеру
путіну
моя ніби так їм ми назвамо свами і ми
її на орних у нашій стратегії
аятів та на аккаунт htc j
я кандидати у канцлер та шульця
доводиться більше зосередитись на
внутрішньої німецької політики али
безперечно на дні в харчуванні європейських
цінностей schule зал і хитається не оре
на